dann werde ich am 19 april ende dieser
woche mit videobeweis in dieser springs
servus s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
diesem kleinen block ich habe heute die
ehre
er war es bekannt machen zu dürfen für
was die meisten von euch wird mich
wahrscheinlich verrückt halten werden
und die idee ist auch tatsächlich
ziemlich verrückt ich war heute übrigens
wieder ewig lange der uni deswegen habe
ich nicht wirklich zeit ist ein
richtiges video aber ich hab was für
euch und zwar folgendermaßen die meisten
von euch dürften wahrscheinlich wissen
dass ich bei den bürgern battle
mitgemacht haben oder noch mit macher
von mcdonald und dass ich dann meinen
bürgern bahn wird mir passiert habe ich
wurde leider wieder überholt und mein
konkurrent ist jetzt auf platz eins ich
bin auf platz zwei und er hat 3000 woods
vorsprung auf mich das ist die lage
momentan und ich werd wetten abschließen
ich erkläre die ganz kurz in dem video
das wird alles sei in dem video heute
der link zum burger ist und in der
beschreibung gleich noch was er machen
soll könnt müsst wie auch immer es wird
folgendermaßen aussehen am achtzehnten
ist das neue battle event in münchen
wenn ich für baden-württemberg gewinnen
das heißt wenn ich von den bürger kommen
auf platz eins bis zum 16 april dann
werde ich am 19 april ende dieser woche
mit videobeweis in die dieser springen
die isar ist ein fluss der durch münchen
fließt und ich werde von einer brücke
war in die isar springen versprochen da
geb ich mein wort drauf
wenn ich wenn ich in baden württemberg
gewinne und am 18
nach münchen fahren darf für baden
württemberg weil ich meinem bundesland
gewonnen habe dann springe ich in die
isar mit videobeweis versprochen
der link ist und in der beschreibung für
den bürger ich mach's garantiert das
sage ich euch gebe ich mein wort darauf
verbreitet den link gerne für mein
burger votet teilt ihr mit euren
freunden keine ahnung auf facebook
benutzt auch facebook teilt den gerne
auf facebook sagt oder leuten auf
facebook dass ihr den teilen wollen
facebook funktioniert gut für so was
habe ich gemerkt dass auch wieder eine
facebook page mich überholt hat
also wie gesagt verbreitet den wenn ihr
es wollt dass ich in dieser springe ich
werde garantiert machen versprochen aber
ich mache es nur wenn ich das battle
gewinne bis zum 16 april auf platz eins
bin dann mache ich das wahrscheinlich
komme auch schon ein video von max ist
schon online wie gesagt versprochene ich
spring darein garantiert wir sehen uns
wieder nichts video haut rhein maas gut
und wollte motto lautet ja